bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filecho ce numéro est consacré au
chômage des seniors une catégorie
particulièrement touché par les
difficultés de retour à l'emploi dans
les Yvelines 22 % des chômeurs ont plus
de 50 ans pour parler de ce thème nous
allons rencontrer deux seniors l'un est
en recherche d'emploi l'autre a monté
une association les quinka citoyen pour
faire bouger les
choses Frédéric bordeau bonjour bonjour
on entend généralement par senior les
plus de 45 ans vous avez 48 ans vous
habitez à Montini vous êtes comptable
fournisseur vous avez connu un
licenciement économique en 2009 et
depuis la situation est compliquée oui
j'ai pas retrouvé depuis de CDI
j'ai fait des petits emplois en intérim
et en CDD jusqu'à fin décembre 2012 et
depuis je suis re au chômage et j'ai pas
retrouvver plus depuis d'emplois stable
en tant comptable fournisseur et vous
avez d'ailleurs travaillé dans dans des
secteurs qui ne sont pas forcément qui
ne sont plus la compable fournisseur
j'ai fait selon les opportunités du
marché par l'intermédiaire des agences
d'intérim et en fonction de ce qu'on m'a
proposé avec les rémunération qu'on m'a
proposé aussi c'était des poste de de
quoi exactement d'assistant chat
essentiellement à côté de vous on
retrouve Jean-Marc coursin bonjour
bonjour vous avez connu aussi la
difficulté de retrouver un emploi en
tant que Senior ça vous a poussé à créer
l'association quinka citoyen en 2005
alors le but était d'interpeller la la
société sur ce problème est-ce que
finalement c'était parce que ce point
n'était pas assez pris en compte à
l'époque ah oui tout à fait c'était un
je dirais presque un tabou dont il ne
fallait pas parler alors que c'était une
hérésie économique et sociale c'est un
problème pour vous plus sociétal c'est
un problème de reconnaissance des seiors
ah oui pour moi c'est un problème
sociétal culturel alors certains parlent
de jeunisme et cetera mais c'est surtout
il y a en France deux choses si vous
voulez qui se qui se croise depuis plus
de 30 ans c'est le phénomène de chômage
de masse qui est centré sur les jeunes
et sur les anciens et quand la crise est
là et que ça devient de plus en plus
difficile la discrimination augmente et
donc les signors se trouvent fortement
impactés pour vous Frédéric ce n'est pas
forcément un problème seulement d'âge
c'est aussi un problème de
reconnaissance financière vous avez
travaillé 25 ans ben vous avez un acquis
et que vous considérez pouvoir valoriser
financièrement et on vous répond non
monsieur ce n'est plus possible c'est la
crise c'est difficile on peut pas vous
donner cette rémunération d'ailleurs
vous avez accepté finalement des postes
là récemment beaucoup moins payé que ce
que pour pas être chômeur à vitam etnam
oui j'ai pris ce qui se présentait qui
n'était plus le métier de comptable qui
était assistant achat avec des
rémunérations inférieures à mon métier
de comptable de 2008 pour travailler
pour pas faire chômeur chômeurs chômeur
chômeur pour vous aider dans votre
démarche vous vous êtes tourné vers face
nous étions présents lors du premier
rendez-vous avec cette fondation je vous
propose de regarder ensemble le
reportage sur ce
suivi c'est par hasard que Frédéric a
connu le club fast une fondation d'aide
contre l'exclusion une de leurs actions
accompagn les seigors au chômage en
février dernier Frédric ass à la
première étape de ce suivi personnalisé
un atelier pour mieux se préparer aux
entretiens d'embauche j'tais un
entretien au BTP on m'a dit vous n'avez
pas les deux pieds dans le béton bon ça
sous-entend vous êtes pas dans le métier
et puis un jeune peut-être qui sera plus
disponible que vous il nous coûtera
peut-être moins cher après il faut
trouver des solutions Gilles l'animateur
cherche donc à transformer ses
demandeurs d'emploi en offreur de
compétences un moyen de mieux percevoir
les compétences acquises au fil de leur
carrière de à 3 semaines plus tard le
groupe se réunit pour un bilan de leurs
avancées ici il s'agit d'un autre pooule
mais la démarche est la même l'atelier a
trois étapes la rencontre
perfectionnement de leur posture et
ensuite rencontre en entreprise dès lors
que j'ai bien compris ce qu'ils veulent
ce qu'ils ont envie de faire c'est pour
nous beaucoup plus pratique beaucoup
plus évident de dialoguer avec le monde
de l'entreprise et de les présenter en
entreprise parmi les présents
aujourd'hui Olivier 44 ans depuis le
premier entretien il se sent moins isolé
et arrive mieux à se projetter dans
l'avenir le hasard fait que je dois être
différent puisque là j'ai plusieurs
entretiens qui ont marché des processus
de recrutement en cours Olivier a donc
bon espoir dans d'autres cas le club F
peut les mettre en relation avec des
entreprises partenaires c'est la trè
étape du processus on fait l'effort de
justement de les représenter en
entreprise et ça marche parce que ils
ont eux-mêmes repris confiance qu'ils
ont clarifié leur projet
professionnel et que on n'est pas dans
le circuit classique de l'offre d'emploi
avec la discrimination qui ne se dit pas
mais qui se fait encore sur l'ARGE un
petit coup de pouce pour les aider à
retrouver un emploi le club F annonce un
taux de réussite de 70
%.é bordeau finalement que vous a
apporté cet accompagnement par face déjà
une écoute de de la recherche de
l'emploi et puis une mise à des
compétences et voir si c'est cet
ensemble de compétences acquises depuis
25 ans on peut pas les tourner ver un
autre métier et retrouver un emploi
durable et stable avec un vrai CDI et
une rémunération décente
l'accompagnement de face vous a
peut-être aussi apporté un peu plus de
confiance en vous un peu plus de
relation avec des gens déjà qui ont le
même problème et une discussion avec
d'autres personnes qu'on ne connaît pas
qui n'ont pas fait le même métier et et
qui sont aussi plus âgés que vous et qui
rencontrent autre chose et puis voir
chacun sa réflexion chacun ce que ce que
chacun apporte à chacun quoi c'est un
c'est un échange Jean-Marc Ain pour vous
aussi gagner de la confiance en soi est
important c'est notamment parce que la
recherche d'emploi est plus longue pour
les seniors les
statistiques
aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui a plus
de 50 ans en moyenne est inscrit à Pôle
Emploi 467 jours c'est pratiquement 6
mois et demi de plus que la moyenne
cette tendance a tendance à augmenter et
mais le problème qu'on a avec les
signors c'est qu'à un moment donné ils
disparaissent de Pôle emploi parce
qu'ils passent à la retraite ou que
comme ils sont en fin de droit ne
s'inscrivent plus à Pôle Emploi donc on
ne sait pas s'ils ont retrouvé vraiment
un job ou non et là c'est un vrai
problème parce que on fait des pauvres
pour demain pour caricaturer Frédéric
parlait de communication c'est surtout
le lien social qu'il faut de surtout ne
pas rompre parce que en France on veut
traiter le chômage simplement en
rémunérant les gens à ne pas travailler
entre guillemets hein mais surtout ce
qui leur manque c'est le lien social
c'est qu'ils ne sont plus reconnus ils
n'ont plus l'impression de de vivre en
tant qu'être humain hein il y a une
espèce d'ostracisme qui se crée et là on
peut rentrer dans une spirale
descendante si on ne va pas dans une
association on peut justement créer du
lien communiquer échanger si on reste
dans son coin on peut disparaître très
vite au niveau mental c'est quelque
chose que vous avez ressenti vous aussi
bien sûr parce que on n pas d'autres
accompagnement on a rien sur les
organismes nationaux il y a pas de
solution pas de en non plus donc on a
personne en face pour nous aider n
motiver à la limite même pour n dire bon
attends faut faut repartir il faut
rebandir il faut faire quelque chose
Jean-Marc coursin vous évoquiez en début
d'émission un problème sociétal et un
problème de reconnaissance politique les
choses ont un peu changé depuis une
dizaine d'années il y a notamment
récemment la création des contrats de
génération h je vous propose de regarder
l'éclairage que nous avons
réalisé pour comprendre ce qui'est
concrètement un contrat de génération
nous nous sommes rendus à une petite
séance d'explication de la directe
direction monte la ville le 18 avril
dernier à l'occasion de la Journée de
l'emploi Manois
Caval TR objectifs je vous disais
l'intégration durable des jeunes en
emploi le maintien ou le retour en
emploi des seniors et faciliter la
transmission des compétences c'est ces
trois enjeux forts du contrat de
génération pour signer un contrat de
génération il faut donc un jeune de moin
de 6 ans embauché en CDI et un senior de
57 ans et plus maintenu en emploi pour
sa mise en place et les aides de l'État
tout dépend de la taille de l'entreprise
dans les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés pour tout contrat de génération
PUL emploi versera 4000 € d'aide par an
et par binô pendant 3 ans dans les
entreprises de 50 à 299 salariés cette
aide est conditionnée à un accord
collectif ou de branche attention si
l'un quitte l'entreprise pendant ces 3
ans et qu'il n'est pas remplacer son
aide part avec lui pour les entreprises
de plus de 300 salariés pas d'aide mais
l'obligation d'un accord collectif sans
cet engagement ces entreprises subiront
des pénalités dès le mois de septembre
selon la directe les entreprises
accueillent assez bien cet annonce dans
le département d'ors et déjà il y a une
dizaine d'entreprises il y en a SEP dont
j'ai la connaissance qui ont déjà
bénéficier de l'aide donc ça veut dire
que le dispositif est lancé il y en a 68
en Île-de-France et 7 dans les ivelines
au niveau national l'état espère
atteindre 500000 embauches sur 5
ans Jean-Marc coursin sur ces emplois de
génération est-ce que cela vous semble
suffisant est-ce que ça va assez loin
non le il y a pas de recette miracle le
contrat de génération B on va voir ce
qui va se passer mais j'ai toujours pas
compris le signor devait être licencier
donc on le garde et on embauche un jeune
là je comprends pas très bien puisque
les entreprises qui licencient des
signors il est lessenc parce que
officiellement ils sont obsolètes en
terme de compéten donc je VO REP tout d'
un coup pourquoietrouverz de la
compétence donner des des compétences
obsolèes à des jeunes bon ça c'est une
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que il y a pas une recette et pour un
segment de la population active c'est un
problème qui doit être traité d'une
façon générale et nous euh ce qu'on
propose ce n'est pas des mesures pour le
signor c'est une mesure générale dans
l'emploi c'est-à-dire concentrer la
formation 32 milliards d'euros quand
même par an sur ceux qui ont besoin d'
la formation et tout au long de la vie
c'està-dire faire augmenter la formation
des signors quand ils ont 45 ans de
faire en sorte que la moyenne de
formation soit la même que pour les
autres catégories d'âge et la deuxième
chose c'est on sait qu'on va devoir
travailler plus longtemps ce qu'il faut
c'est avoir un travail soutenable donc
ce sont les conditions de travail aussi
bien physique que mental or il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui les modes de management
deviennent très anxiogènees par rapport
au au salariés donc c'est pas ce ne sont
pas des mesures qui sont à prendre pour
les senors ce sont des mesures qui sont
à prendre pour que les seniors soient en
capacité de travailler jusqu'à 70 ans
pourquoi pas et c'est pour ça que nous
propose aussi un bilan d'étape de vie
professionnelle tous les 7 ans qui
englobe toutes ces problématiques de
façon à ce que le salarié soit un acteur
éclairer sa vie professionnelle Frédéric
sur ce point de la formation est-ce que
vous ressentez vous-même une certaine
obsolescence est-ce que vous vous
ressentez un un manque finalement dans
les compétences aujourd'hui qui ont
volué bien sûr là je vais rebondir
directement sur ce qu'il a dit monsieur
c'est que euh j'ai jamais eu de
formation de ma carrière 25 ans jamais
aucune formation professionnelle
j'entends aucune tout ce que j'ai appris
je l'ai appris sur le terrain par mon
bon vouloir donc aujourd'hui ben j'ai
plus les compétences qu'il faut j'ai pas
de formation j'en décroche pas parce que
c'est il y a pas les budgets parce que
c'est trop cher parce que ça c'est pas
finançable par pour l'emploi et autres
et ben je suis bloqué parce qu'il y a
des logiciels qui ont évolué parce que
les logiciels ont évolué que on vous
demande des langues étrangères que on
vous demande des choses que vous ne
connaissez pas et que si on ne vous les
apprend pas vous ne pouvez pas deviner
et ça vous fait un critère de blocage à
l'entrée je vous laisse quand même le
mot de la fin vous vous restez confiant
pour l'avenir non non non non non je
vois pas d'évolution en à l'écoute de
toutes les informations on entend sur
tous les médias je vois pas bien une
évolution de l'emploi dans des délais
brefs même plus long j'espère que que
vous en sortirez assez rapidement quand
même merci en tout cas tous les deux
d'être venu sur ce plateau merci merci
avant de se quitter on regarde ensemble
l'agenda une date à retenir si vous
voulez bénéficier de l'accompagnement de
la Fondation face rendez-vous à la Cité
des métiers pour un atelier le 22 mai
c'est la fin de ce filcho merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve pour un
prochain numéro le di
[Musique]
mai
for